dans quatre jours les britanniques
diront définitivement adieu à leur reine
elizabeth ii doit être enterré lundi
prochain au château de windsor à lons
l'occasion pour nous de se plonger dans
l'histoire de la famille royale et ses
liens avec la touraine c'est en effet au
château de candé amont que son oncle et
loire 8 épousera wallis simpson en 1937
ce mariage du siècle comme on l'a
qualifié à l'époque fit trembler la
monarchie florent clavel en 3 visite
d'elizabeth ii en val de loire le
domaine de candé n'a jamais eu les
honneurs de la reine il aurait pu après
tout c'est ici que son oncle edouard 8 à
épouser wallis simpson en 1937 mais ce
mariage somptueux celui du siècle selon
la presse de l'époque est en réalité un
séisme pour la famille royale donc juste
ici à droite de la cheminée on aperçoit
encore la signature du coup plus windsor
ces mariages et les polémiques et les
historiques avant toute chose puisqu'en
fait pour réaliser ce mariage edouard 8
va abdiquer c'est à dire qu'il renonce
volontairement à ses missions de rois et
empereurs afin de privilégier sa vie
personnelle donc c'est un cataclysme
pour la famille royale et la monarchie
britannique à ce moment là le mariage de
caen décèle la fracture au sein de la
famille royale à plus d'un titre georges
6 père de la reine elizabeth 2 succède à
son frère
insuffisamment préparés handicapé par un
bégaiement il remplira sa charge au prix
de sa santé un épisode qui laissera des
traces il va énormément travaillé pour
réaliser de meilleurs discours
s'exprimer à l'oral et il va également
énormément fumée donc quelque part et
d'ailleurs la reine mère en tiendra
toujours rigueur à edouard 8 et wallis
simpson et bien le fait de fumer
énormément va contribuer à sa mort
puisque on sait qu'il va mourir d'un
cancer des poumons
le couple windsor ne reviendra jamais
sur le sol britannique sauf à
l'invitation du roi la reine elizabeth
ii elle rencontrera une dernière fois
son nom sur le point de mourir lors
d'une visite privée à paris en 1972